is Jennifer Lawrence  natural blonde are any of we  do I keep I'll hold it and you peel it  oh okay  is Jennifer Lawrence  good at I'm assuming that says archery I  could kill somebody if they move slowly  enough  um  is Jennifer Lawrence Hispanic I regret  to say no I am not is Jennifer Lawrence  related to  um I am actually fun fact related to  Jeremy Renner that's really that is true  somebody did An ancestry report on him  and turns out we're like third cousins  or something whoa so where's my present  Jennifer moving to Lincoln Nebraska  I hope not  um but maybe I haven't been informed of  something I am moving to Lincoln  Nebraska